I'm from Argentina, I'm currently in
Argentina, the pandemic won't let me leave
here, but I started developing wow,
when you browse the status
currently in distribution, the first
versions of Netscape, I don't know if
some of those who are here in the
audience come from that  time and then
they eat I also dedicated myself to
mobile development to make mobile applications I have been
giving courses, conferences and consulting to
a lot of large and small companies,
both in the US, Latin America and
Europe,
as Diego said, you will find
a lot of my content in many
online course publishers and  books and I write I
like to write so I write a lot
the two topics in which I have written in
recent years are web performance which
is the topic that we have today and also
priorities and games
and I will probably launch a filter site
that is a compendium of all my
articles, talks and free content
that I have generated but well
I do not have the objective of talking to you about
myself well my objective today I have two come I
have two objectives
but active that they feel you if I want you to
feel bad
that is going to be the  first objective that
I have today the second objective is that you
can learn some tricks in
some new tricks that until now you did not
know well so let's see if
I achieve these two objectives in the
next 25 minutes
let's start now I know that you already know I know
that  You know well, I'm Argentine so I'm
going to shout a little bit about talking, I
know that you already know several things since
its users are sad about this fruit
and in addition to knowing that money is good
bringing a little more to education well
of laws with Mexico
let's put a little Mexican pesos but they
are losing money who is the
developer of the website or the owner of the
website when we are developing for a
client the client is losing money
because because the website is slow well
this is proven no  I know that when
you know so I'm not going to dedicate myself to
explaining this is much more
and this is mainly the responsibility
of the front end we are in six comes so it
is not our
complete responsibility but we have a great
responsibility in the performance of a
website  It has nothing to do with the cloud
with the cloud there may be problems there
but it is not the most common of the most common that they
are border problems.
In addition, I know that you already know that there are
metrics focused on it,
lately the ones we are using are
the one created by  google what would be the
vital signs of the website
korb itunes the vital signs of
aguaderas a set of metrics
oriented to the user's perception
because how do we measure the performance of
a website if we are going to do it by our
perception of what it does with my mobile and
I say and quickly  I
don't know how much that was in my perception and
another problem we have is that hair
was an old metric that
we used when I started in the
90s doesn't make any sense today
so today the most common ones are calculated
around the 75th percentile which  Speaking
quickly and soon it would be that of all your
visitors 75 percent have to
meet a certain minimum both on
mobile and before
the most social metric today is the stupid ones
in the skeptic which is basically the one
that best measures the initial load how
fast it loads  the content the age of
the first impression the first
page then we have force input airline
that measures the interactivity how
interactive on our website or how
problematic it is when we want to
interact to track touch click and it does
not react
[Music]
what they do well with this  quality and I'm
sure you have seen that sometimes we
have some problems when we
enter a website we are reading
and suddenly a banner or something appears that
moves the information that we were
reading about the place and it bothers us that
annoying user who simply doesn't
like it  our website and that is there are
more metrics speed index time force bite
suárez counter full pain which is
when the first pixel or the
first background appears and both interactive is when
the website works they are all
metrics based on the user but
many of you will be saying but hey
this is not my problem my website runs
fast because because we test it
carefully we test it with our with
our mobile that if we are here it could
be a larger mobile phone the average with a
larger average connection because
we work on this and  We have a good
connection so we do not measure well
today the objectives that we have to achieve
these objectives set by the community
and a little sponsored by Google seem
sincere but a community more or
less is following is that in the
contexts Payne must appear in  2.5
seconds, that is, for 75% of
visitors, in 2.5 seconds
the most important content should appear up to 4
seconds is acceptable but we are
all already regular more than a quarter
second we are in trouble
the first in good life is 100
milliseconds the ideal is 300  the maximum and the
live, this metric, do not look at a thousand
seconds, it is a metric that does nothing, the
ideal tool is 0.1, which
means that the web moves little
once it is drawn and 95 is the
maximum that we want.  Also point out,
I already know that you already know why
you are at this conference and it is like
Mexico that we have to optimize the
transfer of resources, we have to
reduce the number of files that
we download from the server for the
screenshot started, yes, but we have
to compress  the html the ss these
qinghai kids are everything that is
text must be compressed next to the
server I already know that you know that you have to
work with accents and http 2 that is to
say that having that ensured and this base must be
supporting http 2
today  for every website and every
pretty girl
I also know that you know how to use css as an
appetizer like ape thaiser what is this
in our main meal what is the
content or the service that we offer
css is the appetizer should be as
small as possible the appetizer is small
we  We are going to eat four
appetizer tacos. It will be an appetizer. It must be
small and it must be first of all good
in this case because the CIM CCS the
browser does not draw anything it would not learn
anything and xavi is the dessert goes at the end
it is very sugary so it has has
a  important energy consumption power,
the dessert is very sugary
and in the end it must be
deferred because because it uses the
same execution frame that the browser uses
to render and do its calculations to
draw the water,
in addition, you know how to optimize images,
no  You are going to publish a logo that starts at
4 megabytes, well, then I see the
technique of removing, well, we know that that is
wrong and that you have also passed it through a
tool that compresses the png or in
old age there is the jpg and I also know that you know how to
use service  works well something that has been
mentioned in other law talks with
all this you already know no you are already
doing all this this is base
we are doing all this obviously
of course I trust you we
still have a problem because what is
the problem because we are talking  Of
this in chai it is as if we are all
doing what we have to do
the problem is that today the average by the
median but let's say average so that it is
better understood
so much interactive that is at what
time
a website is available to scan
to touch the  average of 9.3 seconds
good in the world for websites on
average 9.3 seconds this comes from the
hdp foundation now kaymer who does
these analyzes constantly this is
updated now this say pod max
9.3 seconds is not much good let's
see how much it is
9.3 seconds
9.32  or existence
hurt that when we saw it we are longer the
time
9.3 seconds is a lot imagine that you are
waiting for the train the subway the subway that's what they are
called Argentina or the bus or the
truck it depends on the country where you are and 9.3
seconds you can decide well in a
pandemic don't worry  I'm going to take
public transportation a lot but you can decide
between I missed the train because I didn't see it
well or being able to take the nine points of
seconds a lot of time for a Shakespeare
the page takes more than three seconds
53 percent abandon it
this is based on  metrics of a
landing page
and it's three seconds and we talk about the
average of nine then there is a
problem there is still a problem we
have always underestimated the mobile world
well in many ways there are
ios and android mobile worlds we already know we are not
going to discuss other things in this
moment but that means that that is
safari and chrome strictly I have a feeling
that it is not that simple
today there are many browsers that
have
enough of the market
to force us in some
way to try to test our website
[Music]
work  mini the last one is chrome well but
not any other
and I am sorry to all of you who know that you
are users of iphone or ipad
chrome the iphone is not chrome
in appearance great it was a
chrome aspect the chrome icon but it is not
chrome not because it was  a loss for the
moment the publication of other engines
and there is another browser that no one
considers any web developer that
I know or designer and
ever tested in this browser and
that is this one
facebook facebook brawn being a
built-in browser it is called facebook mobile
browser when you click or tap
on a Facebook post and it has an
external link, by default it opens within
this browser and travel is not the same
engine as the browser that you have
installed on your phone, it is different
in performance and capacity  ipiales
that we have available in in
script version things that we can do and that you
have not ever tested your website
or you up and act view now and throttle on
facebook mobile browser
even a friend on twitter
last week I asked him if he had data on
any percentage of people are
currently using we have left the
visits are from facebook power browser
he has a report that calls
mobile over the report where he gets
statistics and from his latest
statistics it is that 7.6 of the
global smartphone traffic comes from the
application of  Facebook is a lot there are a
lot of millions of users and visits
and we have never worried about testing
accident
the other problem that we have on mobiles
that we use the cellular network
and many of you are thinking but hey
max we have four genes we no longer have to
worry much about  the proforma
more of the performance well let's see for a
second this is the latest information from
the j of the work this woman you will see gsm
which is the global organization of all
telephone companies well today 65% ​​of the
people in the world have smartphones
so there are  a 35 who do not use smartphones
but who
always have the 2019 is 52% of the children
in the world in Latin America it depends on the
country but on average Latin America is
a little lower around 47 48% that
is, there is another percentage one would say
uses  3g but if we look at the following
graph from the right 3gs 25%
we already have the kind of turquoise that s
4g 3g 25% and the gray
[Music]
many people continue browsing in Doha
today even in the US in some areas of the
United States  I know that 4g
is not necessarily the solution yet
when we talk about 2g 3g 4g our
brain quickly identifies
bandwidth very clearly 4g has better
bandwidth than 3g and 5g
has it in four gestures 5g still does
not appear in two in the percentages  It is
still a very very small percentage of
5 g in the world
but bandwidth is not the most
important thing to generate performance in
the navigation of a web page, it is more
important to be able to see one to be able to
see
Netflix in 4k well today that
Disney's came out  different mutual plans for
Latin America if we want to see it in 4k and
if we are going to have to have more
bandwidth but to navigate when we browse the
internet we are downloading a lot of
files but very small, very
small and it is not so important the
bandwidth is more important  the
latency the round suite pan, which is the
time it takes for the information to go back and
forth to the server,
of course, as
the generations increased,
that latency decreased, but now I was limited
between 4g and dsl of cl 95 g, tell you  It is a
local connection that we have in Garín and
a cable connected to
our router in our house or it could
be an ADSL or
4G, the latency is still ten
times higher, that
is, the percentage of people who
have 4G is not all.  Even that
percentage has a higher latency, that is,
each package that goes well was more
so we still have many
performance problems and I even
tell you the following, there is something called
chrome light pages. I don't know if you have
heard of crown light
pages.  73 were
two well if the user enables an
option called 20 to 6 see well data saving
if you enable it that today appears the
first time you open chrome for the first
time on your android that this
option appears what happens is the following
crow instead  to show your website or
tube ebap will show a live page if
the user is on a 2g network or if they are on
wifi 2 g4g or 5g but chrome estimates that
the force content full time of your
website is greater than 5 seconds times five
second solutions you will not see anything
immediately with it says let's go to
light mode and that is the na mode and you will say well
the light mode beyond having an icon
identifying that it is a light page what it
does is render our website
on our website  in the cloud, not in the
client,
well, which changed the landscape a little,
there are smart optimizations, whatever that
means, an optimization is
human and not all images are taken care of
by default, we have that on
our website,
I think we don't want to have control of
What happens and another issue for which
performance today is important are the
flowers and guards, these were these
websites that can be installed, this
progressive today can be in the
Google store of this, for example,
well one in handball flowers in the United States is
a  double track in the store the
official application of kobe 19 from panama is called
panama food is in the store but
for that you have to meet a minimum
performance of 80 the lighthouse which
is a tool of the estuary so
this is something very important  we have to
hack web performance we have to
do even more so now in the
next few minutes until the dose is
feel bad I hope it made you
feel bad
what to
try to show what more we can do
to improve this so the next
tiny ones I'm going to try to  give you new
tricks first we are going to hack the
initial face of the website and for that we are going to
try to avoid more than one bone trip to the
server so that when it arrives in the
server package that is enough to
draw enough so that it does not
feel satisfied in a  first and first
screens well for that we are going to use
something called tease ipys logo start I am not going
to get very very dense here with the
topic of networks and time
like the image on the servers today are
based on linux we have a cap of 14.6
carib for the first packet if the
first response from the server occupies more
than that it will come in two packets and
generate more of a round trip to the
server time since I will be thinking of
waiting a second each time it will be a
small parenthesis which is this of the
Caribbean I ask you a question and you can
use the chat
if you want to give the answer quarters
the bucks believe believe that there is a kb well that
many for one
how are you going to ask this in one time
at most well let's see the answers
in the chat
many  They go to 1024 bars in a kilo, wow, they
are 1024 bytes,
I regret to inform you that no, and this is the
only thing you will remember from this
conference,
unfortunately, I would like you to
also remember one kilobyte in
Millbank, and if you believe me,
ask Siri,
ask her.  Google, ask
Wikipedia, you don't have to believe
me, what
we know as what in 1,024 is
called Kuwait, which takes one and in the
middle, Bianchi, viva, viva, viva,
etc. then well, a Kuwait is 1024
white, returning to avoid more.  From a
ranking
we have to achieve a package of 14.6
I wrote bytes and how much descent how do we do
to get our website to enter
14.6 it seems very bad we
have to separate the website between
what is below the background that is
above the fold well  What would be what is
seen in the first step of what
was below default but which is
below the scroll well the idea would be to
deliver the ate but which is above
the scroll at 14.6 kim and you download the
html baby all that cdc  and all the kid
who doesn't center and 6 place add a logo
embedded in base 64 or images in low
resolution 14.6 is very little but we must
remember that this is compressed
html is exiled for now and that can
be between 70 and 80 gigabytes or kb
and 80 affect eighties doesn't sound so bad
now for that little piece of window
so this is the first trick second
trick avoid the re direct http https me
going to james com.mx and why don't I type
https 2/3 as immediately the
browser tests  go to http I don't go to the
insurance and the hdp in demand to the insurance and
that wastes time there is
a way called hsts that allows us to
define the header by telling the
server 8 to the client to the browser
I fish x it will always be
and now I always had to  going directly to
https we avoid that first reality
that can take up to half a second and we
can also do it h that counter
more than me you know a
white list or a bird that say
regular non-blocking list and from new
users who never entered  our
website is going to go directly to https
we call the cool tricks called
data transfer
it is important to start using http 3 which
is built on a protocol called
quick it is still in let's say beta it
is almost finished they work on you
for those who know about networks  Don't
worry because Quick adds what is
necessary so that there is no
packet loss and reduces the latency of
message congestion well and can
greatly increase the proforma
developed by 10 percent without touching.
In addition, my task today is available in
crown and that is a lot  more users
in Latin America and there are on iPhone, for
example, it is already available as an
experiment that has to be
learned from settings but it means
that it will soon be available to
all users and it has the same
interface as http 2. They have to learn
nothing new  It's the same thing, just that they have
changed the transport protocol,
well, use Brooklyn, this is something that is
configured on the server,
Rodriguez can also give up to 25 points and
this is a compression algorithm,
format and compression algorithm that
allows the HTML, well, these  14 points
6 that you live can put more 7 average
inside well up to 25% more yes it is
important to verify that this is
placed on the server
that is enabled
then hack the loading of resources for
example let's talk about modern cache
what is this me  I understand that all
of you already know how to cache but he
said that this is what I remember for a
long time, the web programmers
were enemies of Elche
as an excuse in the calls the client
told me I don't see the change and one who said
excuses you must and the cache well  the
truth is that today the cache should be
used intelligently and that is all the
static resource
if that is css images software should
be with an expiration of one year a
very far operation well so that to
maximize the possibility that the
resource is already in client  Today it is very
common to have hashes in the
file names, angular shower would be used and it is
other other libraries or frameworks the
life process generates the hash resources
be the main band a
js chat is not called main bando it is called main
bando nor a hash and  If we make a new
virus
with which, since this is a very
common pattern, there is a new header so that
the browsers do not make a
conditional request and this is the browser has
that javascript
our html searches for javascript but the
truth is that it says to express better and a
new version  We are going to ask the server,
all that takes time because here on the network,
as we know that this resource is not going to
change, what we can do is use the
minute controls if we say cascón 30,
today it is compatible with all the browsers,
the browser knows that it will never work.  to change
that file on the server because it was
options in the url so it will never
be a conditional quest well so
that is interesting
then warm up engines many times
we download resources from other servers
well images files out free and
we can help the browser to start
that connection with it two servers so
that they start as soon as possible, for
example the ns query can take
150 milliseconds and a tcp ls connection
200 milliseconds over a cellular network
and one can use and announce the
ns queries with it has spread date
is a link  where we notify you in the html
sent that later we will go to small
resources of this domain because this is
how things are going for us, you begin to see it as soon as you make
the ns request, we could even
tell you that you have already connected to the
server until you start doing the
sending the private and public key
open the hard and jane of the
secure connection begins to do it because soon
we will need it
and also then you can announce in the
header in the response of the html the
save a within the content of the html
and finally  we can preload
preload is to help the browser
manage the priority of downloading
resources with a link but for example
we can notify the browser that we
are going to balance the css file and we
can also do it in the headers for
example we can tell it that we are going  Let's see
that opening a wolf font before
the browser knows that there is a ccf in
a css style sheet and that that
css style sheet is going to require a web file, we
already tell the browser to start
downloading the web file because because
if  the typography there is no text on
screen text screen we have bad
metrics for example the network with texts
paint so we go ahead and
tell the browser to start this
earlier
even today we can also add it
through bryant and jeans or
priority aids through the
important attribute we can tell the jeans
and the ing what their importance is
then we can help the browser to
download the images that we
prefer before others through the
important this is interesting and
speaking of images
hacking images
has to do with what we know  that an
image is worth a thousand words well
we know that this is known the problem
is that it goes down if we do not see the
image it is not important for that
this is fundamental today they add this and
many sites better in
performance immediately place in love
adding  loud in life and what it will
do is that all the images will be downloaded,
but it will start downloading them
when they appear on the screen or when
they are about to appear. Well, they are downloaded.
For this example, the ones we see above
all that also work for
iframes banners  For example,
and the ones that he doesn't leave pending when
I'm not there, he starts scrolling to
write to him and says, "We're going to add more
images and you'll download the downloads, but that
helps you to download
other resources that are more
important to others,
then and  Finally, it is time to
replace jpg in the last section that you
have to do. For this, we have, for example,
Google Bing, which is a format that
reduces the size of AVI files by up to 22%,
which is new. Well, David
can conquer 40 percent.
nothing macro mendes yet not even on
android it's going to come soon in
opera and it's about to reach false so we
can start using the images
are smaller we can take advantage of the
space for other things and if you don't
like these new formats
less keep using png but change the
compressor there is a new compressor called
soft link that allows you to reduce 20% and
these compatible ones from our friend
our friend and try to explore well with
everyone
and what jpg is we can put them in another
new compressor also called get free
they are  German names so it is not easy
to count for me so this is
important with the images and finally to
finish it is important that it is here
in what you know here I speak known if
you use react angular beauty is
other frameworks other
client libraries think that  It is more important if
our clamor and love for that bookstore or
performance and even if you don't like it the
answer is the proforma because
we are not doing performance for the
proforma itself because because we are
or I am a fan of that but because it
is approved that  The higher the performance, the
higher the
conversion, the higher the conversion, the more money for someone, the
more users, the more visits, the more
income, the more registrations, the more purchases. This
is proven,
so that's why we want to do it. So
when we use these libraries, we have to
start changing our minds and thinking.
If it is necessary to do something servers there is
at least for the first load such
as energy and it is un that it is
even moving to static generators
such as gas or the event and well the
blogger net field point of causing him 20
which is Austin I run it  on my computer
and the process generates
static files that are purely static
and
and it set me up with a new one that was
a little more web performance
performance in the first one always
good because if performance there is no
conversation the convention is the one that
ends up investing the money to  that
we make a development
whenever we try to push more and it is
really worth the effort it is very
important that we keep that in mind
you feel bad I hope so I hope so so well
that was all for
today thank you for what I leave you  If
you want the book hacking web performance
on my blog it's free, well it's the
last book I wrote with some
topics that we saw in this conference